Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harowitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy with important information about
the alliance between the increasingly
violent black lives matter movement and
Islamic supremacist groups in the United
States nihad aad the executive director
of the Hamas link Council on American
Islamic relations care said it plainly
at the 14th annual mass ikna that is
Muslim Aman society and Islamic circle
of North America Convention in December
2015 this is what Awad said black lives
matter is our matter black lives matter
is our
campaign Khalil as Sabra another Muslim
activist told the Muslim conference
basically you are the new black people
of America we are the community that
staged a revolution across the world we
are the
community that staged a revolution
across the world if we could do that why
can't we have that revolution in America
with the recent murder of five policemen
in Dallas by a sniper during a black
lives matter protest that Revolution may
be upon us the revolution of hatred and
violence that Islamic supremacists and
race Hustlers both have worked so long
to bring about Awad and Sabra were by no
means the first to identify their own
efforts with those of the people who
want to bring about a race war in the
United States the far-left counter
current news reported this in January
2015 recently a number of
representatives from the Dream Defenders
black lives matter and various Ferguson
anti- police brutality protesters made
history through a solidarity trip to
Palestine this little group toured the
West Bank in order to see for themselves
the purported link between oppression
emanating from the Israeli State as well
as that which victims of police
brutality are experiencing in America
Ahmed Abu naid of dream defense ERS
explained the goals were primarily to
allow for the group members to
experience and see firsthand the
occupation ethnic cleansing and
brutality Israel has levied against
Palestinians but also to build real
relationships with those on the ground
leading the fight for
Liberation now what was the purpose of
building such relationships abuid
continued he said in the spirit of
Malcolm X Angela Davis stokeley
carmichel and many others we thought the
connection between the African-American
leadership of the movement in the US and
those on the ground in Palestine needed
to be reestablished and fortified as a
Palestinian who has learned a great deal
about struggle movement militancy and
Liberation from African-Americans in the
US I dreamt of the day where I could
bring about power bring that power back
to my people in Palestine this trip is a
part of that process another activist on
the trip Charelle Brown delved deep into
left it conspiratorial fantasy as she
claimed so many parallels exist between
how us police incarcerates and
perpetuates violence on the black
community and how the Zionist state that
exists in Israel perpetuates the same on
Palestinians this is not to say that
there aren't vast differences and
nuances that need to always be named but
our oppressors are literally
collaborating together learning from one
another and as oppressed people we have
to do the same so expect the same
tactics to be employed in both Wars by
those who wish to kill and
destroy the New York University chapter
of the radical students for justice in
Palestine the SJP repeated Brown's
equation of police forces in the US with
the Zionist State saying this just after
the Dallas shootings in the past 48
Hours another two black men have been
lynched by the police the total number
of black people lynched by cops in 2016
now totals 136 we must remember remember
that many US police departments train
with the Israeli Defense Forces the same
forces behind the genocide of black
people in America are behind the
genocide of Palestinians what this means
is that Palestinians must stand with our
black comrades we must struggle for
their Liberation it is as important as
our own Alton Sterling is as important
as Ali dwabe Palestinian Liberation and
black liberation go together we must
recognize this and commit to building
for it after getting criticized for this
the SJP issued a clarification here it
is our statement regarding the murders
of Alton Sterling and fando Castile and
the rampant murders of black Americans
by the police was not a suggestion that
their deaths are part of an Israeli
conspiracy Israel did not literally kill
either of these men that much is obvious
what is also clear is that American
police departments and the IDF train
together the IDF assists the NYPD and
other American police departments in
their oppression and murder of black
people these groups share a common logic
that manifests in several types of
Oppression white supremacist racism
among them if we in the SJP and in the
Palestinian solidarity movement more
generally are serious about ending
Israeli oppression then we must stand
with black Americans we need to be in
the streets with them and we need to
organize against police
brutality counterterrorism investigator
Kyle shidler noted in town hall last
March that this emerging revolutionary
Alliance goes back as far as the first
outbreak of disorder in Ferguson few may
recall the attendance at Michael Brown's
funeral of care executive director nihad
Awad in November of 2014 Fox News
reported on an effort by care Michigan
director dud wed to link the death of
Michael Brown at the hands of police and
the death of lukman Abdullah a Detroit
Imam shot during an FBI raid Abdullah
was described by the FBI as the leader
of a nationwide Islam Islamic
organization known as the umah Run by
convicted cop killer J Abdullah Amin
abdullah's group engaged in criminal
activity in order to raise funds in
order to for an effort to establish
Sharia law in opposition to the US
government care and the SJP have clearly
hitched their star to the black lives
movement and are retailing its
distortions in Dallas they saw what
their backing both leftists and Islamic
supremacists want to destroy the
existing order and replace it with a
system that they contend will be more
just and free of racism both leftists
and Muslims have resorted to violence in
service of this goal and both will do so
again Hamas link care itself does not
openly Advocate violence but it shares
the goal of every violent Jihad group in
the world to impose Islamic law Sharia
wherever it can be imposed and
ultimately over the whole world as Hamas
link cares Ibrahim Hooper said back in
1993 I wouldn't want to create the
impression that I wouldn't like the
government of the United States to be
Islam
sometime in the
future whether black lives matter and
its allies will accept Sharia is an open
question but in the meantime subversion
of the existing order by both violent
and peaceful means precedes a pace the
defamation of police with wild and false
accusations also precedes a pace the
murders in Dallas regardless of the
Cosmetic condemnations from black lives
matter which fly in the face of its
incendiary rhetoric reveal how all these
Allied groups will manifest their hatred
and accomplish their goal of
Destruction did nihad Awad have five
dead police officers on his mind when he
told the M ikna conference that black
lives matter is our campaign would nihad
Awad who has publicly expressed support
for the murderous Jihad terror group
Hamas have stopped short of saying this
if he had known only awat can answer
that but in the meantime the alliance
will continue to wreak havoc I'm Robert
Spencer